by welcoming you everyone
a for this morning session i'm juan i'm
going to be
the chair of the next two sessions i'm
very excited about it because there are
topics that are very
interesting and i still like have
planned to
to
to attend this uh these two to two talks
so the first talk would be
a given by daniel and velmet uh and they
are
coming from that coder driven vault
and they're going to talk about yeah
extremely dashboard and applications
into like machine learning and
production that's very very
exciting so please give them a round of
applause
so before giving you the stage please
remember to turn off your devices
a
ask questions through slido and please
take a pictures and tweet
what's happening here so this stage is
all yours thank you very much
thank you very much so uh yeah welcome
everyone
let me start off by saying that this
title is actually a little bit of a
clickbait title
because
the title says how a simple stream the
dashboard will help you put your machine
learning model in production
but actually it's more of a story
about how a streamlit dashboard helped
us put our machine learning model at
ball.com into production and by sharing
this story with you we hope you can
learn something from it as well
and maybe in the future it might help
you as well to put something in
production
so let's start off with a quick question
who have you have built some data-driven
applications in python either machine
learning or some other form
of data science or data yeah basically
all of you kind of what you expect at
the pi data conference really nice
then a second question
who of you have struggled to get a model
into production
nice yeah not nice of course but i'm
very happy to see that because then
maybe this talk talk is useful
but i think before we can really answer
this question
we need to define what we actually mean
with production and i think there are
two
kinds of production that you can talk
about
on one hand you have a data science
model that's deployed and running
somewhere on some infrastructure and
it's accessible
and on the other hand you can have a
data science model that's actually being
used by a user and that's providing
value to the company that it's in use
for
and in this talk we're talking about the
second thing
so given that we have a model given that
it's running on some some production
ready infrastructure and whatever how
can we actually get the user to be
willing to use it
so
very brief introduction to ourselves who
are we and why are we actually talking
yeah i think vomit can uh start good
morning um well moot i'm the product
owner working at the ball.com i will
tell you later a bit more about this
company so i'm only mainly focus of
course on the value that we deliver so
and that will be my part of this
conversation yeah and my name is daniel
i've been a machine learning engineer at
go data driven for about a year now and
for the past 10 months i've been working
well with steam trying to get some
models into production
so i think we are in the same boat as
many of you have been or still are we
struggled to get our model in use
but in the end we managed and that's
what we want to share today
see how this works
um how is that the previous one right
that's the right one oh
um so i'd like to tell you a little bit
about our company to get a little bit of
a clue what is it actually the the the
growth that we're working on
um this is a quite a complex picture but
the main takeaway is that we are
[Music]
an online
store
working in the netherlands
started already quite a while back in
1999 only selling books
but we started off as a books online
started off in a porta cabin very very
small so very entrepreneurial
and then in 2002 we
took our own
weren't
any more
connected to the books online worldwide
we started on our own and we emerged
with quite a lot articles
and also
[Music]
went into belgium so we're now focusing
on belgium and the netherlands
and just to get some of the figures
what we're talking about so we are
working in the netherlands and belgium
and i have to read the numbers as well
so there are 13 million customers
that we're currently facing
and
quite some visits a month you can see
with a lot a lot of products
we already grew up to five warehouses
still growing
and we deliver more than hundreds of
thousands of parcels a day in the
netherlands and belgium
our main base is utrecht
being part of arjun delges
and from the 2400 employees now working
at bowl we're now working with 50 data
scientists and that number is also still
growing
i'd like you to tell a bit more about
what was actual the thing we were
challenging
well over here we've got this customer
ordering three
articles and of course in the end he's
expecting a parcel at his house
um
but we have five warehouses
and then you get
to the to a new challenge at least a
logistical one
since not all articles are in the same
warehouse so they are scattered among
different warehouses
and then of course you get the
logistical question
where do you sort which article and what
do you put combined in one parcel that
you will send to the customer
and we used to do that based on cost we
had one warehouse then we had two that
was quite overshable
we created a model and looking at costs
what was the best combination
but then we saw sometimes that one of
the warehouses was reaching its capacity
we had a solution to that as well we
took our controller some people
being in office and trying to steer away
from that warehouse and still managing
to get all the parcels all right
but as it as i said already earlier
we're growing and growing and the
complexity is just getting too large to
be overseeable by an employee so this
controller way of working was working
but not for the future anymore and
that's where data science science came
into place
we were asked to create a decision model
to automatically balance
between capacity and cost so still cost
but also taking into account cost
so the team started up together with
daniel and a lot of other data
scientists worked very very hard we had
this tight schedule because we wanted to
be ready before october when our peak
season starts
and we were so happy because we created
this very nice working model right in
time
but then we had the next challenge
we had this guy with his controller
still in his hand saying well
what do you think you give me
uh
he was not happy at all so we started
some discussions
and we found out actually that we were
giving him a black box and he was still
holding his controller and still wanting
to be able to steer and to make sure our
customers got a right
parcel right in time
so
that's where the question arise
why didn't the customer didn't want our
model so basically for in our internal
employee but he wasn't
happy at all
so daniel yeah so we thought it was
really interesting because
this internal customer or the user of a
product he was actually they were the
ones who rang the bell and asked us hey
can you deliver us this model we really
need it we really want it but at the
moment where we wanted to deliver it
eventually they they put on the brakes
and he said yeah no
not so sure about it
so
what
what happened and to try to explain it
at least from our experience
i want to go back a little bit to how we
as data scientists tend to build a model
and develop some applications
so
this is a picture of a data scientist if
you google data scientists this is the
first one you get super stereotypical of
course nice tie shirt always glasses i
think
maybe it looks a little bit like me
um
and of course all the fancy graphs that
you as a data scientist never work with
but they still showing it so yeah that's
our data scientist right
and when we get
put on an assignment we start working
basically often start with some data
exploration hey what is the data what
can we make of it and from this data we
get some nice insights
maybe we can even develop a predictive
model something like that
and then in the end what we
not always but very often what we want
and in this case as well these insights
they
influence certain actions
and the actions that we were influencing
was what packages are going to what
warehouse
and we hope that through
our insights and through the actions
that we're influencing we end up
providing some value to the company
right
in this case we're reducing the capacity
on some warehouses such that more
packages could be sent again from them
and that way we could increase revenue
at a little bit
increased cost but that would be well
worth it
so
as data scientists we do all this this
nice analysis we make some nice
notebooks and then we develop a model or
even application in our case
and then we we get the user of course we
already involved the user throughout the
process
in this case you can recognize the user
by the fact that they're the ones
actually doing the work they're busy
running the business
and then
we get back to the user and we say yeah
we have developed some things we show
them a very nice jupyter notebook with
all fancy graphs maybe a powerpoint even
and we show hey we tested our algorithm
it works perfectly trust us
and then
we give them the algorithm
and then we uh probably have a couple of
meetings about it where we say yes it
works look at this in this kpi
and then the next step is of course
yes it's machinery model looks
complicated that's always how these
things look
and then the next step is of course you
get a really big fence
and you take your machine learning model
and you try to throw it over the fence
to the customer
and at least this is what we did and
if i look back at it now yeah surprise
surprise the customer didn't really like
it
because we we had these nice graphs we
showed them hey
it all worked right trust us
you see these graphs as well right now
and then we took them away because they
were still only in our presentation only
on a notebook
and then they just had to believe us
i think this slide is the most important
slide of this presentation and that is a
model entering use requires trust from
the user
and that trust can be built up through
continuously giving the users these
insights that they need
rather than only once giving them in a
presentation or maybe during testing
giving them at the moment when a model
enters use when it's actually
influencing
their responsibilities because they're
responsible for the business
then they should be able to see hey
what's going on
as i said the user is in the end
responsible
so why don't we just show them what
they're responsible for and show them
how our model is influencing what
they're doing
and then of course when we when we're
discussing this also with velmoot
we have a mixed team of software
engineers and data scientists
and machine learning engineers and the
software engineers immediately thought
oh we can make a very nice web app for
this
javascript java kotlin react i don't
know whatever they all wanted to use and
on one hand it's a super nice idea but
on the other hand yeah the incinerator
takes a lot of effort
and i think here where something like
streamlight can come in you don't have
to make it very difficult it can be
super easy to build a dashboard to show
these insights
because
what we as data scientists have done
when we were building up this pyramid
we've been using jupiter notebooks we've
been coding all this stuff already in
python usually for ourselves to see how
well is our model doing we've even
showed them in a presentation to our
users
and then if we have this jupyter
notebook
then we can fairly easily
convert this jupyter notebook into a
nice dashboard with tools like streamlit
and i think streamlit is maybe just one
example i think uh plotly dash might
also be one i think there are more
python based tools but i do think what's
super nice
is that if you use a python based tool
for it because you already have the code
in jupyter notebooks and that's just
ctrl c ctrl v
maybe writing some extra stuff behind it
but that's it
so who of you have already used streamly
before i'm curious
about half of you okay so then maybe the
next part will be a little bit basic for
you
but
yeah i've been talking about how easy it
is to do this and why you should do it
basically my message for the last 2-3
minutes
so i've been preaching this but i always
heard practice what you preach
and we're at a pike on event
so i think it's better to just show you
what we're doing
live coding is always scary so uh let's
hope it works
is this readable now
on the right side i hear no nose so
that's probably a yes
all right so what i have here on the
right side is a very simplified version
of the one of the notebooks that we were
using for evaluating our model
so we have some data that we load in in
this case order data from customers
and we see how our
our algorithm our model influences the
decision to which warehouse it was
sourced sometimes it was the same
sometimes it's different
yeah and now these are fake numbers
because we couldn't share the real uh
numbers because we're currently in a ipo
so we're not allowed to share any
numbers but just uh for the for the idea
it's just the same yeah so we made up
some fake data
ideas still same and we can also load in
some nice warehouse data
and then we can of course show this in a
graph hey during the day how much orders
are going to which warehouse and if i'm
looking at this graph
i see in this case a warehouse called pk
is fairly busy it appears right
so if i'm now our user i might expect
hey
that's not so nice what's going on why
is this warehouse so busy
again super simplified version if we
then look at a little bit more insights
to it maybe this could be a model
predicting how busy or where it's going
to be or in this case just very simple
what is the fill rate of a warehouse so
how much remaining capacity do we still
have
and there we see that our peak warehouse
is actually least filled
okay given these insights what do we now
expect our machine learning model to do
we expect it to move packages away from
bfc and firework towards peak because
peak
has the lowest
has still the most remaining capacity
well the way we steered is through
assigning penalties to these different
warehouses so we make
we make a fake calls that we add to each
warehouse so that busy routes get a
little bit more expensive in our
algorithms and
very empty warehouses get a little bit
cheaper
and that's exactly what we see here we
see peak warehouse during the day
getting a negative penalty which means
packages are being steered away from
this warehouse
and then finally what is the consequence
of the actions how are the actions
actually happening in this case we see
indeed at our bfc warehouse
we have a negative item difference which
means packages are being steered away
and on peak we have a positive item
difference which means packages are
being sent to that warehouse so indeed
our model is behaving as expected
and then the final step of this pyramid
that i was talking about is the value so
how do these
these actions how do they actually
influence the value of our business
in this case i have made up two two kpis
one is the cost per order in this case
we see as we expect the cost per order
goes a little bit up because we're no
longer purely steering based on cost
they're also steering based on capacity
in this case it's about three cents per
order so i think that's uh that's doable
four cents
but what is the effect on the free
capacity so the lowest free capacity
that we have on a certain warehouse well
originally we would have gone over
capacity so there was going to be a
warehouse that no longer could deliver
its packages
with our steering method we now achieved
500 packages that could still be sent
from that warehouse
i think that's a that's a really nice
result
so this is something that we could show
in a presentation to the to the user
i would really like this for the user to
see at any time to just go to the
dashboard and see this
so what i'm going to do right now is
convert this notebook
into a nice dashboard
and that's how it actually started
because they were showing me like okay
well we've got this the model is working
and then i said well can we show this to
the users because if you already have it
well come up with something and just
send it over by email every hour i don't
care just make it
quick
i want to go live
so no fancy stuff just do it yeah and in
the end we actually found like rather
than sending over the notebook every
hour that it was easier to do so
i'm just a product owner always looking
for solutions so okay the first thing
you do if you want to make a streamlined
dashboard you import streamlit i think
most people do the import streamlight as
sd
and then you can basically do exactly
the same thing as you do in your
notebook
so when you execute your stream descript
or when you when you refresh the
dashboard page it basically just
executes python code
if we want
in this case i'm just showing here the
the data frame
streamlight has a very similar thing to
that it's called st.dataframe
and now i think we have our first
dashboard i'm going to try to run it it
will give me an error
so it even says oh you don't need to run
this python script you need to run it as
a streamline dashboard fair enough
that's what we're trying to do
so going to
here
and now i have my nice streaming
dashboard nice it's a little bit ugly
but this is like the first version
already being online and you can just
make it in a docker docker container put
it somewhere on a virtual machine and
then
you can have it running and then you
have your
very nice model or in this case just a
data frame showing here
of course doing other things is just as
simple i'm going to delete this data
frame because i don't really like
showing all this raw data on my
dashboard
but then here
doing some
showing some figures so in this case i'm
using plotly express
to make the figure in the notebook
well
we can do a very similar thing
and then one of the nice things is my
dashboard when i'm running it locally it
automatically also detects hey i changed
something
so let's rerun it and then i see
yes indeed i now have my beautiful graph
here as well
let's actually convert the whole thing
just to demonstrate that it really is
that easy
and so one of the things you might now
be noticing is
what ends up happening is every time i'm
refreshing this dashboard
basically the whole codes get rerun and
right now i'm just loading in some local
files with what you probably end up
doing is reading some data from bigquery
right where your predictions are or
reading some data from some database or
from a bucket
and then at some point it might start
taking time your dashboard might become
slow luckily there are a lot of caching
functions in here
so it's super easy to just cache some
data and say i only want to refresh it
every let's say 10 minutes
and that for us it helped a lot because
the data we were loading in it wasn't
that small so it took a couple of
seconds
similar to just writing a data frame or
writing some graphs you can also do
st.right
that's just showing some text
and here we have our kpis already
so
of course you can go all out to this you
can make nice text it's super easy you
can just type markdown in it
put the function st markdown around it
put the mark down in a string and you
have some nice layout as well
quite a lot of functionality of course
it's not going to be like as nice as
super
fancy dashboarding tools
or super fancy custom web apps but i
think that's not the point of what we're
trying to do with these kind of apps
just in 10 minutes i already
built this or maybe even i think he he
signed me like i had 10 minutes left no
5. when i started oh you tell me you
started i have 5 minutes left so that
means in five minutes i built this
dashboard pretty proud of myself
so
let's go back to the
presentation
so yeah
this is super easy to do
and i think
that is the power of streamliner or the
python based
tools you can use for this
it doesn't need to be fancy because the
user is only going to use it a lot
during the first couple of weeks when
you have to build up the trust and it's
just such a little investment to do this
and it can help you tremendously to
gather that trust
i think that makes it an awesome tool
so velma can you share with us
what has happened when we did this yeah
you can do the slide i think
because well
of course we always like to have this
happy end so this is how it
actually ended
we had this a very happy customer so
they're actually they are still using it
looking into the graphs daily
and of course
in the first few days they were looking
at it very very closely
then we got a few moments that they said
oh the system isn't working right and
then they looked into the data said oh
actually it is it's just a little bit
smarter than we would have done it
and i think now it only occasionally
when something really
an abnormal day is happening that they
really look into the graph so you see
it's the use getting lower and lower and
because the trust is going up um and we
will see what we will do in the future
if we keep some of the graphs and then
the software engineers can go their way
or that we we don't use it but and in in
the few few
days i think when we used it we actually
added some extra insights as well so i
think that's also great because you can
iterate very very fast uh just
change the code and also change the
dashboarding so i think this is
definitely a way we will be using now
again with the next thing that we're
implementing
oh yeah and by the way oh yeah you saw
his controller you see it it's lying on
the ground because he's actually he's
not using it anymore
yeah thanks for sharing this wonderful
ending to the story so what did we end
up learning as a team
from this whole
thing that has happened well first of
all a model entering use apparently
requires trust from the user because
otherwise they won't use it maybe fairly
obvious but i think it's an easy pitfall
to fall into
and then
getting a dashboard to show these
insights to show a little bit into how
your model is working and what decisions
is it making that can really help the
user to get this trust
now you might think it's a big
investment but no not really
building such a dashboard can be really
easy
so with that i would like to leave you
with the core call to action are you
struggling to get your model use
turn your notebooks into a dashboard
thanks for your attention
i think there's now a time for questions
right i was just looking in at them so
because we have a couple of questions
let me go
up so that i can see you all
all right thank you very much for this
very interesting talk so we do have some
questions which i'm going to read out
loud so the first one is have you run
into any limitations with respect to
layout and interactivity uh in this case
yeah so i think um
to be honest we just didn't care that
much about layout right we just want to
show the graphs we just wanted to show
the data
so if we ran into anything we
fairly easily just said hey never mind
we're not going to do that
putting some graphs next to each other
is super easy putting some graphs
in different orders or different
locations making the graphs nicer that's
also doable of course because you're
just using some graphing library in our
case plotlia express
so i didn't really run into any
difficulties i think if you want to
really push it further right now you're
still very much at the
the basic stream layout and the basic
streamlet theme
i think you can change these things as
well but then probably it gets a little
bit more complicated and then
maybe at some point you need to also
start thinking hey is streamlight still
the right tool to do or am i actually
trying to do some more fancy stuff
that stream that maybe is not meant for
all right there's another questions
about
how did you deploy hosts this streamlit
app and what about authentication
yeah good question
so deploying a streamlit app
it depends a bit you have two options on
one hand you have i think a managed
version of streamlit uh if it's called
streamlet cloud where you can host your
streamlet application
through
streamlater company haven't tried that
what we ended up doing is
hosting our streamlit application
on a kubernetes cluster on
gcp why because the kubernetes cluster
was already available it was for us it
was super easy to to get it running onto
authentication
not sure about how to do that in
streamlit so for us because we were
running it on this gcp kubernetes
cluster we could arrange the
authentication from there so we could
only allow our specific users that we
wanted to see it could allow them to see
it
but if you just want to run it yeah
fully custom somewhere not sure how to
do the authentication
all right thanks
another question is what's the main
advantage
of extremely comp as compared to dash
sorry the yeah the advantage of using
streamlit against dash for example yeah
so personally i don't have experience
with uh dash
so i really can't answer that question
okay very difficult
a
another question is can streamline
dashboard can be easily automated in
continuous integration
um
yes i think so um
not sure what part of continuous
integration he's getting at because in
the end it's just a bunch of python code
but we bake it into a docker container
and then a docker container gets run
somewhere so
that whole pipeline you can of course
you can do it in ci and cd as well yeah
maybe
maybe doing some unit tests on the
python code of the streamlive app yeah
so
and what i did just right now i made it
one big script
which is of course not a nice way to do
it you can always extract these things
into uh into packages or
modules and that way you can make it
definitely a lot more testable
how much you can really make the
streamlit part testable i'm not sure
with all the data processing you can of
course
you can of course do that
all right yeah there are other questions
related to the what that ones that i
already mentioned so we don't have that
much time but i do want to read one
question it's a what's a good reference
to learn more about streamlit
sorry what's it a good reference of like
how to learn about streamlit like what
would you recommend so for me and this
was also a
really learning experience for me but i
think the documentations of streamline
are just really nice they really explain
everything well and
it's super easy to get started with it
so i would just start at the docs
all right thanks so please let's thank
the speakers again
and yeah thank you very much